i'm very very excited about these two
recipes today so
keep you fueled through diy week
so shall we kick it off so the first
recipe we have are salted peanut butter
cookies
now this recipe is actually from one of
my
personal favorite bakeries called ovenly
and they're based in brooklyn new york
that um just makes ridiculously good
desserts
we're gonna feature them in our small
business gift guide oh my god that's
amazing
they're really really inspiring and
tremendous so let's get started so first
ingredient
up we have here um a cup and three
quarters of light brown sugar
and we're just gonna whisk in really
quickly two
eggs so that's two ingredients we're
whisking away we're whisking away
and i didn't even believe you when you
wrote out the ingredient list form
literally five ingredients that's one of
them being the salt topping at the end
yes exactly third ingredient half a
teaspoon
of vanilla that's so delicious
so we're just gonna keep on going over
here
and then the fourth ingredient is the
peanut butter
of course one bowl one of my favorites
one bowl which is
so good okay so what you're looking for
is
that the batter is fully combined so you
don't have streaks of peanut butter
or egg or sugar anywhere so that's looks
pretty pretty good
and you can actually start forming right
here but what they actually recommend
is freezing the dough for just 15
minutes
yup i always remember that step yeah
basically when you chill the dough
it helps you scoop out
the cookies a little easier and here we
have a chic ban
lined with a little parchment paper that
just makes a clean up a little easier
and i'm just going to start scooping
these out
just like that really nice and easy and
they're not going to spread the
tremendous amount so you don't have to
like space them out like crazy
and before you bake them you're going to
sprinkle a little bit
of that crunchy sea salt so while i'm
scooping this out drew do you want to
get us started on your recipe over there
all right so for your main
now that we've tackled dessert um and
you can actually prepare this
while the cookies are baking yeah
absolutely um okay
i want to make you my favorite uh
it's called the cali tartine
and what it is is it's a delicious open
face sandwich and it's about as easy to
make as anything you've ever
done i'm going for a whole wheat toast
today
with cream cheese now i usually like to
use my cream cheese as sort of a way to
adhere some of the looser products so
i'm going to use some lettuce there
because that's sort of
the trickiest to stay on
and then i'm also going to add my tomato
now one tip that i have
about tomatoes is that i like to salt
them
so that you really get a nice flavor out
of the tomato you can even put a little
pepper on there
and then i'm going to add some cucumbers
on there
it's such a fresh sandwich i really like
it has all this crunch and texture
and then with the layers of the
different flavors with the lemon
and stuff it's it's just really really
lovely well you actually gave me the
idea to top it off with
the lemon that wasn't something that i
had ever really thought of
yeah so you can go at the end and do a
little lemon squeeze
now what i love about this sandwich so
much
is pilar is right you can really
definitely have a choose your adventure
i always think that you need a creamy
base on that bread but an alternative is
avocado another alternative is
a tofutti a cream cheese that's actually
not
dairy which is going to be a lot less
fattening let's face it
another thing you can do is i love this
brand base culture because it's a paleo
bread and it's completely grain free
so you can actually make this sandwich
so dietetic that it's like
eating air or you can layer it and be
a little more indulgent if you want but
either way
it's so simple and so easy
and just like that you can eat it with a
nice little napkin
on a beautiful little plate and a fork
and knife and you instantly have this
gorgeous restaurant quality sandwich
okay so i'm gonna pop these in the oven
350 degrees for 20 minutes 350 for 20.
yep and you want to rotate them halfway
through basically that's
right the freezer detail and the
rotating halfway through were always
steps i could be like
do not forget do not forget those steps
all right
shall we sandwich shall we cookie so yes
first of all i'm cooking
because let's face it c is for cookie
it's for me they taste like peanut
butter
and with the salt on top i mean oh my
god dude i'm so old
ovenly so good we love you
we love you so much they're the best
peanut butter cookies i would love
as a social experiment for you to write
into the drewbraymare show.com
and tell us what you think of this
recipe of about cooker ever
i love it we're going to do dessert
first and now we sandwich
yeah i couldn't resist
this probably isn't going to sound like
the right description but i just feel
like i ate an
entire produce section that's the most
delicious way
ever it's it's really really delicious
and sometimes just making yourself a
meal like this is such a gift to
yourself
thank you for having me drew laurie love
you so much